rumors of a death of a Schengen are
exaggerated yesterday we had first
political discussion on the new Schengen
proposal from a commission and the
debate was really intensive but
constructive the case where to have to
strike the right balance between freedom
of movement and our internal security we
all agree but benefits from a Schengen
area are undisputed the cost of
non-schengen would be devastating at
political financial social and also
emotional level in our fight against the
terrorism it's more and more pressing to
have an account of foreign fighters
today we discussed how our law
enforcement and intelligence actors can
work more closely together and have
swift exchange of data I strongly
believe that the proposed changes in the
Schengen borders code will makes it
stronger and more resilient allowing
Member States to respond to security
threats when needed while maintaining
the essence of free movement of goods
people and services on the reform of the
common European Asylum system our
overall objective is clear we want to
improve the efficiency of the system
fight abuses and secondary movement and
offer better and quicker protection to
those in need while returning those who
are not in need I made the
recommendation for a further 50,000
resettlement places I'm glad that the
other states have already pledged 25,000
places I'm confident that by the end of
October we will reach our target